breaking news this Friday Nova Scotians
get the all-clear after an emergency
alert about shots fired
just days after 22 people were murdered
tonight the RCMP revealed a timeline of
that rampage rent relief Ottawa's new
help for small businesses the US
presidents dangerous advice what he
suggested could cure the corona virus
could actually kill people
survivors story we could feel the 999 we
lungs and Alberta woman tells us what
Kovach 19 did to her and the treatment
that made her sick and historic high
note
captain Tom more crescendos to another
unlikely world record
global national with Donna freezin
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with breaking news about a
tense afternoon in Nova Scotia RCMP
scrambled to investigate new reports of
shots fired there were reports of two
separate incidents in two neighborhoods
in the Halifax area the RCMP responded
people were obviously on edge an
emergency alert was issued advising
residents to shelter in place and
refrain from travel until being advised
otherwise police said they launched an
extensive search of the areas and later
did give the all-clear but all of this
happened just before a virtual vigil
began for the 22 people murdered by a
gunman on the weekend
Ross Lord is with me from Halifax Ross I
can't imagine the tension there and then
the relief what are police saying well
at first a warning went out to everyone
in Nova Scotia saying stay inside after
a report of shots fired in the Halifax
suburb of Hammonds Plains there were
several other reports of shots fired in
the Mounties say in the end they were
all unfounded they were quick to sound
the alarm this time after criticism they
should have initiated an emergency alert
last weekend that could have saved lives
all right thanks Ross we will come back
to you in just a moment there is already
so much grief in Nova Scotia and today
people paid tribute to those who were
murdered on the weekend 22 innocent
lives were taken in that gruesome
rampage some of the victims were
targeted others were shot at random and
they are being remembered in a virtual
vigil
[Music]
that's Nova Scotia Fiddler's Natalie
McMaster and a pianist playing in memory
of her be McLeod alongside of video of
17-year old emily tuck in the middle
there she loved to play the violin but
video was recorded before she was killed
she was the youngest victim
[Music]
be Brad all kinds of Nova Scotians took
part including country star George
Canyon he said like others he's
devastated by the events of last weekend
and is thinking of the families of the
victims hi my name is Jonathan Torres
and I've lived in Colchester County for
12 years I'm a proud member of this
community as you can imagine over the
last several days people here have been
really trying to make sense of something
that just doesn't make sense
there are still so many unanswered
questions about what happened last
weekend today the RCMP did fill in some
of the blanks Ross takes us through that
the Mounties repeat reporting by global
news that the rampage started after the
gunmen assaulted his girlfriend she
escaped and hid in the woods emerging
hours later with valuable information
for police in the meantime he killed 13
people at or near Port 'epic Beach Road
the RCMP timeline shows at 9:35 Sunday
morning he was 60 kilometres away
killing two men and one woman and
burning down a house in Wentworth after
knocking on a door in Glen home no one
answered the killer drove his fake
police vehicle to another part of
Wentworth along the way he encountered a
woman who was out walking and he shot
the woman at the roadside he continued
toward Deibert a witness described that
the suspect had pulled over one of the
vehicles and had shot one of the drivers
he continued driving down that same road
highway 4 and he encountered his second
vehicle and he shot and killed that
victim at that location
the gunman traveled south on highway 102
towards Halifax shooting constable Chad
Morrison who mistook the gunman's
vehicle for constable Heidi Stevenson's
Morrison survived
came a head-on collision with
Stevenson's vehicle both vehicles
collided head-on Cosmo Stevenson engaged
the gunman the gunman took Gospels
constable Stevenson's life after fatally
shooting a passerby his stealing a
silver SUV he stopped at the home of a
woman killed her removed his police
clothing transferred his weapons to the
victims mazda3 then drove to the Irving
big stop in Enfield while he's at the
gas pumps one of our tactical resources
came to the gas station to refuel the
vehicle when the officer exited the
vehicle there was an encounter and the
gunman was shot and killed by police and
Donna were learning more about the
weapons the shooter used investigators
say he had a handgun and he had long
guns they were able to trace one of
those guns back to Canada the remaining
weapons they recovered are believed to
have been obtained in the United States
and they're not saying anything about
that cross-border investigation at this
time lots more to come on that Ross what
do we know about why the RCMP did not
initiate an emergency alert alert on the
weekend telling people a gunman was on
the loose
well we've suspected this all week as
informations been dribbling out but
essentially they confirmed today that
they thought they had the gunman
contained in Porter pick a man told them
Audi's he'd been shot by a man driving a
car with police markings that the car
was headed towards Porter pick beach and
that there was only one way in and one
way out
Ross Lord in Halifax thank you the
rituals we rely on in times of grief
have been altered because of the
pandemic later we'll show you some of
the many other tributes to the victims
as people find new ways to share their
grief and support each other
Nova Scotians are also coping with the
impact of kovat 19 today there was some
positive news on that front for the
first time in three days Nova Scotia did
not record a death from the virus here's
a snapshot of the country there are more
than 43,000 confirmed cases of kovat 19
in Canada more than 2,200 people are
known to have died Quebec has more than
half the cases in can
more than 22,000 people have tested
positive there and the number of new
cases in Ontario rose by 640 today
that's the highest daily increased so
far that province has more than 13,000
confirmed cases the outbreaks are worse
in long-term care homes today Ontario's
premier appealed to the prime minister
for more funding to help save lives of
residents in long-term care homes and
Doug Ford applauded those workers who
keep showing up and who were on the
front line of the fight in Canada
nothing's a tougher job than what
they're facing right now just imagine
havin loved one husband and wife brother
sister you know that has to go into this
job every single day they're their
absolute heroes each day of public
health restrictions pushes more
businesses to the brink of bankruptcy
today Prime Minister Justin Trudeau gave
a bit of a lifeline to some that are
struggling to pay their rent
Micro la explains prohibition gastro
House has been a staple on Toronto's
trendy Queen Street for 13 years but
losing thirty thousand dollars a week
was too much for owner Michael
Summerfield's a stomach loans won't help
us deferrals won't help us money is the
only thing that's going to help but is
it just throwing good money after bad
when you can't even put enough people in
the restaurant to make money and pay
your staff and pay your suppliers and
pay the government his doors are now
closed the rent assistance program
announced by Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau too late to save his restaurant
but the plan works like this the
mortgage commercial property owner has
to first reduce rent for tenants by at
least 75% to qualify for a forgivable
loan so the losses are shared the tenant
covers 25% the property owner 25% and
the federal and provincial governments
will pick up the remaining 50% this is
an event that put us into deep freeze
put us into hibernation as it were and
everyone had to stop and hold while we
let this wave of Kovan pass through the
Canadian Federation of Independent
businesses is happy but concerned with
the fine print businesses have to be
down set
percent in revenues to qualified and the
CFIB predicts over 30% of businesses are
losing too much to stay open but not
enough to get the assistance and all of
it hinges on the landlords themselves
they first have to agree to give tenants
a break on their rent 75% of the rent
and none of the rent and an empty space
but it's still a bit of an open question
and one that we're watching very very
carefully as well much of the country
because with over 90 percent of
businesses considered small or medium a
lot is riding on this program microlight
Global News Toronto the World Health
Organization is launching an initiative
in the fight against kovat nineteen
world leaders have pledged to accelerate
work on tests drugs and vaccines they
say they will share what they learn with
all countries the WH o--'s
director-general says the only way to
defeat kovat 19 is with a common
approach the US has said it will not
take part in that initiative even though
more people have died of Kovach 19 in
the United States than in any other
country more than 50,000 people and
they're still dying
yesterday President Trump put out some
dangerous ideas for possible treatments
he said UV lights on the skin and
disinfectants like bleach might work
here's part of what he said right and
then I see the disinfectant we're nuts
about in a minute one minute and is
there way we can do something like that
by injection insider or almost a
cleaning because you see it gets on the
lungs and it does a tremendous number
along so it'd be interesting to check
that so that you can have to use medical
doctors with but it sounds it sounds
interesting to me
in fact disinfectants are poisonous
injecting or drinking them will kill you
as jackson prosecco reports there's lots
of bad advice misinformation and false
hope out there and people like the
governor of georgia are acting on it
they're back in business in Georgia
where the governor defied health experts
and let barbershops gyms and beauty
salons reopen it is a scary time to be
open
Bekka the state has 22,000 active cases
adding hundreds more each day but by
Monday theaters can reopen and
restaurants can resume dine in service
who's coming to dinner
I just don't think they're that many
people right now who are willing
Canadian chef Hugh Acheson says he won't
be opening the doors of his three
Georgia restaurants I'm totally not
prepared to jump right back in with a
really clear set of guidelines
scientific data vacuum you know that
it's savor that battle between science
and politics is playing out across the
u.s. I was asking a question
sarcastically to reporters like you in
Washington President Donald Trump tried
to back away from his own comments about
injecting disinfectants into the body as
a treatment experts to look into it to
look into whether or not Sun and
disinfectant on the hands that's not
what he said Thursday I see the
disinfectant we're not about in a minute
minute and is there way we can do
something like that by injection insider
or almost depleting health officials are
seriously worried Trump's words will get
someone killed
in less than 24 hours a Maryland
coronavirus hotline received more than
100 calls about consuming disinfectant
the makers of Lysol felt compelled to
issue a statement under no circumstance
should our disinfectant products be
administered into the human body and now
the US Food and Drug Administration is
cautioning against the use of
hydroxychloroquine a drug touted by the
president studies into a second drug
pushed by Trump have also been called
off after nearly two dozen patients died
Donna Jackson Prosecco in Washington
thanks an Alberta woman with kovat 19
says she was treated with the drug
President Trump has talked about Judy
Gabriel was critically ill and she was
given hydroxychloroquine it's been
around for decades it's used to treat
malaria as well as some autoimmune
diseases there is no evidence though
it's effective as a treatment for cope
at 19
as Heather Eurex west reports Gabriel is
recovering now but she
still struggling with symptoms filmmaker
Judy Gabriel shot this video a little
more than a month ago
the Alberta woman was in hospital
battling Co vid 19 it was a weird
sensation because you're feeling like
you're gonna walk out and lose it like
you feel like you're gonna die Gabriel
says by the time she shot these she was
actually on the mend recovering after
doctors took a chance and decided to try
treating Gabriel with hydroxychloroquine
an anti-malarial that is currently being
studied as a possible treatment for cope
at 19 I remember just looking over and
saying a little bit scared but I was
just trying to please Gabriel it doesn't
know how she became infected with the
new corona virus she had been living in
Lloydminster when she developed a coffin
late February
but she wasn't tested for covin 19 for
nearly a month by that time my my fever
my headache my the pain in my chest was
getting worse as Gabriel struggled to
breathe she says it became difficult to
think straight it's why worried friends
enlisted the help of a retired doctor
who lived nearby I had to say look if
you don't call 9-1-1 I will call anyone
so that's kind of what I did and the
most important factor was she was living
alone Gabriel believes she was the first
kovat 19 patient to be treated at
Lloydminster hospital within days of
receiving hydroxychloroquine and another
antibiotic
she says her condition improved but the
medications caused side effects - nausea
hives blurred vision and chest pain
nearly a month later Gabriel is still a
long way from feeling well my chest and
back are sore they hurt
breathing is still you know I coughed
when I open breathe but I gotta push
myself to kind of get better that's what
you do she also like to know if she
still has cough at 19 she hasn't been
retested so she remains isolated at home
taking each day as it comes
Heather your ex West Global News Calgary
coming up what kovat 19 is doing inside
canada's prisons
Canada's correctional facilities are
another hotbed for Kovach 19 outbreaks
there are more than 190 confirmed cases
of kovat 19 among federal prisoners and
one inmate has died as Abigail Beeman
reports the virus is creating tension
[Applause]
that's the sound of upset inmates at the
Saskatchewan penitentiary who say they
were locked in the yard in the cold the
recording obtained by Global News is
just one example of increased tensions
behind bars due to kovat 19 no violence
in that case but riots are something
everyone worries about is there fears of
uprising absolutely there's fears but
our members are weighing those risks on
a daily basis there have been nearly 400
cases of copán 19 among inmates and
staff at provincial and federal
institutions the corona virus can spread
like wildfire behind prison walls and
then it spills out into our communities
the numbers come from the University of
Ottawa's Justin Pichet he says most
provinces have moved in the right
direction by releasing in total more
than three thousand inmates who are
awaiting trial out on bail like Shane
Morin better for the safety of people in
there cos it's a small environment when
he showed symptoms more and went into
quarantine at the Saskatoon Correctional
Center only allowed out of his cell
every two days to shower
he says his tests came back negative and
he's healthy now everyone was worried I
was weird I scared right it's a very
dirty place right it's not so clean but
like I've just got to remain like your
hygiene everything in order and they
have clean isn't stuff in them that like
spray things down but I don't know like
it's also pretty scary right like if one
person comes and that's it can spread
right but there is no clear evidence of
an increase in releases at the federal
level where there are more cases and
more serious sentences being served
these are all provincial governments
headed by conservative leaning parties
and meanwhile and unfortunately the
federal government has kind of been
stuck in the mud the Public Safety
Minister said he was concerned
month ago there's a number of things
being examined to address the the what
we believe to be a fairly significant
risk the head of the Canadian Police
Association told the parliamentary
Health Committee he's concerned too but
about early releases as the potential to
add unnecessary stress to an already
overburdened system the head of the
correctional officers union says overall
the response has been reactive when it
should be proactive the bottom line from
Ottawa they're working on solutions but
behind bars the virus moves much faster
than government decision-making abigail
Beeman global news Ottawa ahead captain
Tom Morra tops his fundraising goal and
tops the charts
it seems there's no stopping captain Tom
Moore he's the 99 year old veteran who's
raised nearly 30 million pounds now for
Britain's National Health Service by
walking in its garden and now he's
broken another record with a song he's
featured in this cover version of you'll
never walk alone and it just hit number
one in the UK that makes more the oldest
person to reach number one he bumped the
weekend out of the top spot incidentally
over 82 thousand copies of Morris song
have been sold and all the proceeds are
going to Britain's National Health
Service
nova scotia remembers next honoring the
lives lost
the grief over the murders in nova
scotia is most profound for those who
lost loved ones but they're not alone
people across the country and all over
the world are horrified by what happened
many have friends and family in Nova
Scotia and if they could they'd wrap
their arms around that whole province we
leave you tonight with some tributes
thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
this weekend will be hard on all
families take your time
feel your pain reach out if you need it
and know that we are there with you try
to offer hope to people who have lost so
much let's come together to support
these communities who suffered
immeasurable loss let's celebrate the
lives of those who left us too soon
and I just want to say to my Nova Scotia
family and to my RCMP family know that
know that I'm heating a sigh and wish
for the need and will mourn with you
from the far
[Music]
to your Mountain Stark to your hills in
the stream